buddy I guess so I'll let you guys
settle in while I deal with the boring
bits so I my name is Nick Spooner
I'm a PhD student in my last year here
at Berkeley and I'm going to be talking
about efficient post quantum zk snacks
from univariate some check I explain
what all of these things are hopefully
you have some idea of what everything
means apart for maybe univariate some
check and all of this is joint work with
a bunch of great people so le pants a
song my advisor Alessandra Kaiser
Leo Goldberg Tom ger Dave ogia Michael
grabs a brother's visa and Nick Ward so
let's get started ok so what we're going
to be talking about today is
transparency kiss dogs this is kind of
gonna be our goal and I'm gonna do this
kind of acronym thing that everyone does
so what is the ZK snark it's a zero
knowledge extinct non interactive
argument of knowledge so you have a
prove it you have a verifier and the
proof who wants to prove to the verify
that he knows some witness w which
satisfies some some circuits so such
that y is equal to CX w and y next we're
gonna think of as being public
information and W is a secret and this
this proof system though the way that it
works the prover is gonna write down
some proof to send it to the verifier
then he's gonna go away this is kind of
the non interactive pot zero knowledge
means that the proof doesn't contain any
information about W succinct that the
size of the proof is kind of much much
smaller than the size of the the circuit
the the statement that we're trying to
prove and an argument of knowledge is
something that is kind of
computationally tractable this is a way
of formalizing what it means to know
something so all of these things require
a set up you can prove there require
some kind of setup and what we're gonna
want from our set up is that the set up
is a transparent process so it says just
consists of kind of flipping random
coins this is often called the uniform
random string model it's also referred
to as transparent and in particular
there's none of this like toxic waste
there's no trapdoors that we have to
throw away and so one additional thing
that you might want that we're not gonna
kind of insist on but is also a great
property is if the verifier
extinct so if the time of the further
verify to run is much much smaller than
the size of the circuit notice that in
this kind of picture that I presented
this is not possible because the verify
has to kind of know what the the circuit
is but we'll see some ways of getting
around this all right so how do we build
these these things well the original
construction of stocks is due to Silvia
McCauley back in the 90s he called them
CS proofs and what you get is a snuck in
the random Oracle model so it satisfies
all of the properties that we described
so this kind of a transparent setup
which is kind of picking the random
Oracle the there is lightweight
cryptography in the sense of you know
obviously it's a fairly heavy assumption
but when you actually implement these
things really you're just using hash
functions and you have post quantum
security so you can show that this this
scheme is actually secure in the quantum
random Oracle model also so this is all
great so kind of why aren't we done well
what do these things come from they come
from PC peas so there's a transformation
from a PCP which is this information
theoretic proof system to a stock and
PCP is are not great so I mean PCBs are
great obviously but don't want to offend
anyone in the audience but they are not
great for kind of practical purposes
because the best-known PC peas are quite
big so this like n log to the CN doesn't
look like very much but when you have
when n is the size of your computation
this log to the CN factor is actually
pretty enormous and concretely like we
really want to have efficient
constructions of these things and there
are no efficient constructions of these
things kind of the constant in front of
the n log to the CN is also enormous and
so really it's just very hard to build
these these things in the real world and
if you want zero knowledge things get
even worse so kind of if you want zero
knowledge on the right you need to start
with zero knowledge on the left and this
just makes things even worse yeah
no I mean yeah I mean like symmetric-key
so yeah so I mean I'd like lighter than
you know elliptic curve pairings and
things like this right okay so this is a
shame but uh so we're gonna try and fix
this and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna kind of not give up on what we had
on the right because we really liked it
but we're gonna change what we started
from on the left and what we started
from start from on the left is a kind of
more general information theoretic proof
system called an interactive Oracle
proof if you're not seeing it before
it's a kind of interactive version of
PCP so you have a message
so the verify can send a message the
prover can send back an Oracle the
verify consents and another message the
previous has back an Oracle and the idea
is that kind of the prove our Oracle's
can depend on the verifier messages and
then at the end the verify can choose to
accept it can make some queries and
choose to accept or reject so what is
good about this thing well firstly we
know of IOPS with linear proof length so
that there's a paper from a couple years
ago and then this very recent exciting
work by by Ron an ogre showing that
actually you can get this linear proof
length down to like 1 plus epsilon it's
really a very cool stuff and concretely
there are these kind of papers that
showing that you can implement these
things efficiently
yeah so so kind of they have some kind
of demonstrated practical efficiency
also so that is wonderful so what a what
the the message that I want you to get
is is that interaction and proofs means
that you can obtain kind of bets and not
interactive arguments right if you allow
interaction on the left
you don't actually gain the interaction
on the right but you can kind of do
better you can like have better
parameters on the right
no this transformation I am going to
just assume so yeah it's kind of the way
that it works is kind of how you would
expect you kind of you take your
Macaulay protocol and you apply a future
mayor and introduce that yep yes yes
well it depends on how many rounds you
have on the left but yes the answer is
yes and we can show actually how you can
deal with that so if you have certain
properties of this proof system on the
left like round by round soundness then
this implies that the soundness of the
brew system on the right will be good
but in general yes if you have many many
rounds then you're going to get kind of
an exponential loss in Sammis but if
your proof system on the left kind of
looks all right and most I think all of
the Precision's I know of that have many
rounds they kind of have this property
that they play nicely with this
transformation then you actually don't
lose that much yes linear in the in the
second set yes so this is a so this over
here is like linear like these things
here a linear in the second slice when
you go over here this thing is going to
be much smaller because of how the
transformation works so this what I mean
by thing on the left I mean this proof
system so like we designed an
information theoretic proof system we
apply some transformation we get some
you know we use some cryptography s and
random Oracle's we get like a stock and
so then the problem kind of becomes how
do we design good IOPS
so the goal will be efficient higher
fees and that's what I'm gonna kind of
spend this whole hour talking about so
before I go there I'm gonna introduce
this this language called rank one
constraint systems so probably many of
you have seen it before but I'm gonna go
over it anyway so you have two parts of
the input there's a public input which
is these constraint matrices a B and C
which just square matrices of some field
F and you want to see whether there
exists a vector secret vector Z so this
is the witness over the same field such
that a Z times B C equals C xored where
this x here is the is the Hadamard
product
element-wise product so firstly this
thing is np-complete because you can
reduce arithmetic circuits at to it and
in particular this is a kind of very
efficient like linear size reduction so
that's great
it's they're kind of better for our
purposes than just straight-up
arithmetic circuits because it has this
nice linear algebraic structure that
will kind of use a lot it's as candidate
for Standardization so this is this like
zk proof standardization effort and one
of the candidates for the representation
of statements is Ranko constraint system
and it's also been like used in some
implementations I'm sure this list is
longer now than when I can power the
slide but it's you know people are
actually using this thing and building
constraint systems
so rank one kind of means this like
there's just one vector here yeah I
didn't admit the name identity yes when
I sorry when I would learn when did I
say linear like yeah oh yeah so um okay
so I'm gonna mean Linea in the number of
nonzero entries in the matrix yes so if
the matrices are sparse then I should be
paying linear and I should be paying
like linear in the dimension yeah okay
all right so I'm gonna talk about three
IOPS for wrangling these three systems
I'm gonna kind of go over the first one
in a lot of detail and the second one in
less detail and this one which is from
last week in very little detail and
firstly I'm gonna kind of get out of the
way all of the things that are the same
for all of them so they all have the
same proof length this is these like
Oracle's how long are the Oracle's if
you add them all up they're linear in
the in the size of the input note here
that everything is measured in a few
elements so they're kind of in this
algebraic setting yeah sorry so I should
say so the I'm thinking of n has the
kind of number of constraints and yes oh
so n here is really is really the
sparsity of the is like the number of
nonzero entries in the matrix and in
most instances we that we think about
this like the number of nonzero entries
in the matrix is like linear and the in
the dimension so with like n on roughly
n nonzero entries yeah exactly yes so
the proof length is is linear and kind
of this in this positive the these are
the things that they're yes so the
things on on the left so what kind of
when you do this compilation it kind of
doesn't matter too much what this proof
length is you're going to end up with
like it you take a log of it anyway but
kind of nice to know that on the left we
get something that's popped the query
complexity and each cases is a constant
and the proven time is not quite optimal
it's a it's n log n so kind of what's
going on in every case is that you're
doing FFTs of a domain of size order of
n so this is what's the same with all of
these things and now you know how did I
how do we write three papers about them
while they're they have some important
differences so the original paper Aurora
is a paper for kind of general are 1cs
instances so it supports so these these
like a B and C these are kind of the
definition of the instance and so this
kind of tells you like what kind of
instance you have and the time to verify
in this case is order of n so this is
pretty long right so it's kind of not
very useful for any kind of delegation
or anything like that but it's also sort
of optimal in the sense that if I give
you matrices with n nonzero entries you
kind of have to look at them and you
have to spend time and to look at them
so this is kind of the best that we can
do in the most general case but now
suppose that you have some structure on
your matrices so suppose that they are
succinctly represented in particular
there represents there's a
representation which I'll talk about
later which is a size logarithmic in the
dimension of the matrix then we show
that you can reduce the verification
time down to a logarithmic you can take
advantage of this particular kind of
cygnus and most recently we kind of so
it looks like this is strictly better
than this but it also looks like this is
impossible so what we get is we get a
system that achieves 16 verification for
all matrices with the important caveat
that this is in the holographic sector
so what this means is that I am allowed
to kind of take a B and C and I'm
allowed to encode them in any way that I
like and then write them down and then
like the verifier is allowed to look at
the encoding during the protocol alright
so kind of this is this like holographic
like error correcting encoding of the
input
and Alessandra is gonna talk about this
this afternoon in some more detail but
it allows you to kind of reduce the
running time of the verify so I mean in
this case it's gonna be low degree
extensions in general holographic like
doesn't really pay it like the
definition of holographic doesn't really
pay attention to what the encoding is
well okay we define it I guess I don't
know if there was a definition before
actually in this I guess yes exactly
exactly so the this is also kind of when
you're in the setting you care about
actually how long it takes you to put
the input in encode the form and talk a
little bit about that later
so holographic is a notion in the like
interactive Oracle proofs in this
information theoretic setting where
you're like right sorry exactly so when
you take a and I will explain this later
when you take a holographic proof and
compile this transformation you can
obtain a pre-processing free but
holographic care I mean like you have
actually access to this encoded instance
okay also important to note is that the
query complexity kind of the best you
can get is a centrality of one but this
is using a low degree test which is not
very efficient concretely and so if you
like want to conclude the efficient o2b
test that XI or query complexity goes up
but your efficiency improves
so yep how large is the constant in the
proof sighs it's a it's something like
five or ten or something like that yeah
it's not big yep how big is in the field
the field has to be at least and so this
is really yeah I should have said sorry
this is all over large fields so yeah
exactly so so if you're like if you're
starting with a problem that's not over
a large field then you have to pay to
kind of make it be over this large field
yes so this is a weakness of all of
these things kind of which comes from
the reed-solomon code yes yes so if your
if your computation is natively over
this huge field then you're not paying
anything extra okay so now I'm gonna
talk about how you build all of these
things and they have kind of a lot in
common so I'm just gonna go into the
basic structure and then I'm going to
tell you how you kind of build each of
these on top of this basic structure
okay
so here you have I'm gonna write down
the the ONC s a problem again but in
kind of a more broken down form it'll
seem a bit silly at first but I promise
you that it makes sense so now I'm
introducing an addition to Zed I'm
introducing these kind of three vectors
a B and C and what I want is that kind
of all of these four conditions holds so
eight times that is equal to a beta is
equal to bees you know that equals Z and
then the element wise product of a and B
is C so if you take a take a moment you
should be able to see that this is kind
of equi satisfiable with the original
allons-y s instance but now we have this
kind of nice structure that we can we
can use so we've kind of broken this
down into like uniform parts so these
three we call in check because they're
testing just a linear relation and this
one is called bro check because it's a
kind of about element-wise property and
so what you could do you could design a
proof system where kind of the prover
sends Zed and a and B and C to the
verify and he checks all of these things
right this is an NP proof system and
it's actually you know less good than
the very stupid proof system we started
with but what you can do essentially is
you can take this you can encode these
messages and using the Reed Solomon code
and then this will like give you the
foundation for building the all of the
proof systems I talked about so I'm
gonna talk briefly about the
reed-solomon code just so that we are
all on the same page with what I mean
so the reed-solomon code is a code over
a over a finite field F what you do is
you choose some interpolating set H of
size n where n is a kind of the size of
the constraint system that you you have
and then if I take any vector I can look
at it as a vector of a kind of after the
H so indices in H then I can interpolate
this unique polynomial of degree less
than the size of H such that it agrees
with with the vector V on everything in
H okay
and then the encoding of V is the
evaluation over some other set l which
in general will be somewhat larger and
in particular doesn't actually have to
intersect H it can be anywhere and if I
set the size of L to be rights i
griffith eita of h then this has this
code has good distance and good rate i
do the choose optimal distance and rate
and there has a couple of additional
nice properties firstly we have pretty
efficient encoding like analog an
encoding using the FFT so long as these
domains are kind of nice and very
usefully for us it has the
multiplicative property so if I take to
read Solomon code words I multiply them
together I get a code word that
represents the element wise
multiplication of these two words so
that's the result of encode so what
happens when I kind of apply this to the
ONC s problem so now I have this like
encoded version of the LSTs problem or
the like broken-down one that I talked
about so now we have this set H which is
kind of my interpolating set and I have
matrices which are now over H cross H
and now ever place kind of my vectors
with univariate polynomials so what
happens to each of these constraints
well so this one here is ed equals a
becomes kind of a times there were the
restriction of F said to H is equal to
the return of f8h right this is really
just the same as this thing just written
in a form that makes sense for these
polynomials and the same for B and C and
then the this element wise can trade
becomes kind of for every H and H this
this product is equal to FC and this
thing here is kind of weird when we
check it with making use of this
multiplication property of reed-solomon
codes all right so what might your proof
system look like well you kind of write
down F Z F a FB and FC you send them all
to the verifier and then we do something
to check all of these things yeah FC
aren't you trying to be the product also
outside of H
sorry for which one C F sub C oh no it
doesn't it only needs to be the so it
like FC only needs to like agree with
the polynomials on agree with the
product on H it is not the product of
the two polynomials but you can kind of
check this using kind of standard
agreement testing type things yeah yes
so I'm actually not going to talk about
how you do this this is a reasonably
well known and the kind of probability
checking literature I am gonna talk
about how you do this so this is this is
kind of new to work so F sub Z is the
representation of like the the input the
the secret input right so it's like the
satisfying assignment I encoded using
the reed-solomon code and I send it to
you so notice that she I haven't talked
about their knowledge at all I promise
you that all of these things can be done
in zero knowledge I'm just not gonna
mention it
repeat so FC is just the logic the
encoding of the thing that agrees with
the product of FA and FB on H and
outside of it it's just the sort of
unique polynomial of whatever degree you
want alright he's any so I guess no it's
not an equality of polynomials but what
I can do I can actually tell you how how
you do it basically what you do is you
say I take FA times FB minus FC right
this is a polynomial which is 0 on H and
then I check this is divisible by the
polynomial which is 0
the vanishing polynomial of H and this
is something that we know how to do yeah
so importantly this is not a polynomial
identity okay all right so let's talk
about oh sorry yes I'm sorry yeah this
should be F capital F capital B F
captaincy yeah yes okay so it's the
encoding of yeah sorry okay so it is the
encoding of little a but I cooled them
here if a capital F capital B F capital
C and so they should these you could
should consider the F capital C and that
little seem to be the same as oh yes but
they are actually the encoding is of
little a little B in CC yeah all right
so let's talk about checking linear
relations so I'm gonna move back again
to kind of this the standard like vector
setting so there are no encodings right
now so let's say that I'm given x and y
which are just vectors and the matrix
and I want to check that x equals my
obviously this is something I can do
just by kind of multiplying but because
we're doing proof systems we're going to
do this in a very strange way that makes
sense with proof systems so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to take a vector
of linearly independent polynomials in
in one variable and then if X is not
equal to and y then
the inner product of U and X minus my is
not a zero polynomial this is by the
linear independence of U and this means
that if I evaluate it at some point
alpha then in the field then I'm gonna
get something that's nonzero with high
probability yeah exactly but I mean yes
so I just I take this to be any so in
particular I can take this to be like 1x
x squared etc we actually won't do that
we'll take it to be some other linearly
dependent set but it's the same
principle okay so what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna do a little bit of the kind
of shuffling this expression around so
firstly I can kind of move the Alpha
inside and I can evaluate u at like
every entry of U at alpha this doesn't
change the value of this expression then
I will use the like linear by linearity
of the inner product and split this up
and then here we're going to use the the
adjoint property so I just move this M
over to the other side he gets a
transpose yes so U is a vector of
polynomials it's like you know u 1 u 2 u
3 etc right and each one of these is a
polynomial and so I can take it's in a
product just you know it's a and a part
of it oh oh oh sorry yeah that's so this
should be an end I'm sorry yes yes
you're right so this is actually up to n
yeah so this is an F X to the yes the
the dimensions don't match and but they
should all right there's a answer your
question
all right I'll settle for mostly okay so
now we're gonna do away with these
troublesome ends and keys and things and
we're gonna move to
friend capital H and we're gonna look at
the encoded setting so now I'm given
polymers F and G and I want to check
that kind of effort suited the age is
equal to M times G restricted age so
what does this kind of look like as a
proof system well I have my program I
verify and they both have access to this
F these polynomials F and G somehow so
once again I'm gonna take you to be to
be a vector of linear dependent on the
mules but now it's just indexed over H
same vector but index of age and I want
to check this this inner product this
like pair of inner products so clearly
the first thing that I should do is I
should send alpha right so I'm gonna
pick this alpha random I'm gonna send it
to the pre but then it's kind of not
clear right so how do I test this this
equation so let's kind of unpack it
first I'm gonna write out the inner
product as a sum of products so what we
get is this like the sum of H and H of
these these two these two sums of these
two products so here this is like the H
entry of u alpha and this is the H the
entry and here what I've done is I've
kind of done the multiplication by the
matrix first and then you take the 8th
edge that is real
a matrix times a polynomial does that
give you one hope like M times G is that
one this sir M transpose U is a vector
oh this thing so this is the evaluation
that's oh I thinking this is an H vector
like a oh sorry this is this so that you
should think of this as a like M times
like G H like that so the bracketing is
this way so it's not mg or surgeons at H
is M times G research stage yeah yeah
thank you okay then
alright so what was a yes so so this
thing becomes basically I take this M
transpose u I can like take the M
transpose times u first and then do the
evaluation these things commute and then
I look at it it's value on it's kind of
H entry in this vector and then
multiplied by G of H does this any
questions about this what I've done here
do you mind why F should be
why should f be secret so f in the
protocol is going to be like a tie it is
gonna be the like a matrix times the
secret input and so if I have a matrix
time the secret and put this tells me
the secret of them and so it needs to be
secret also alright so now I have this
and this you know now I've just kind of
made this expression look more
complicated so what I'm gonna do next is
make it look kind of even more
complicated and I'm going to replace
these U and M transpose U with their low
degree extensions so now I have these
vectors which are vectors of polynomials
I activates the polymers and X I can
really extend them in another variable Y
I end up with a bivariate problem so
this by very polynomial is the lower
extension of a Y of this vector U and
this by very polynomial iteration of Y
of M transpose u all right so what this
does with this equation is I can just
replace this with this u alpha sub H
with u alpha comma H and M transpose u
alpha sub H with um where um is the slow
brace tension of alpha comma H
any questions about this XR 5 what you
mean by extension so why yes so it's the
kind of the bivariate polynomial where
if I plug in so here I have kind of you
in F X to the H right and so you like
this this polynomial you of say X comma
H for H and H right this should be equal
to the kind of u sub H this this poem
moment this should be a polynomial
energy yeah and the same thing for the
same transpose you
all right okay then then we have this
expression and you notice that what
we're doing once we fix alpha is this is
a sum of a univariate polynomial over
some set H and the question is how do we
check the sum of univariate polynomial
well you might want to design something
called univariate some check possibly
and I'm gonna explain kind of how you do
this so let's kind of look at the
problem in a general setting so you're
given Oracle access to a low degree
polynomial F and you want to check
whether the sum over the set H of F is
equal to zero okay so this is the this
will allow us to solve a so the problem
on the previous slide for now it's
guaranteed to be a problem yes obviously
in in the real protocol it won't be but
you will use load if you're testing to
deal with that okay so the problem is
you know if we if we don't have any help
from the prove it you definitely need H
queries unless the degree of F is really
really small and if we try you know our
usual approach which is this subject
protocol from the 90s
this gets us nowhere because it's for
multivariate polynomials right in the
first round of this this protocol you
would just send the whole of F and
you'll get nowhere yeah some check and
zero checking to what you're kind of
trying to do right what you're not
trying to do yes
you mean can you because dear at zero
checking in play not that I know of so
you can definitely do this the same
reduction from zero checking to sorry
from yeah from zero check into some
check but the other direction I don't
know yeah I mean yeah okay so what we're
gonna do is we're going to reduce this
problem to low degree testing which is a
problem that we do know how to solve
okay so this is kind of the most most
technical size of the talk so
once you get through these it's a it's
clear sailing so let's take a CH to be a
multiplicative subgroup of the field
okay so we need some structure on H
because kind of otherwise it's it's not
clear how you get a handle on all this
summers and we're gonna take G to be a
polynomial of degree less than the side
of H so this is kind of a special case
and I'll show how to generalize it to
remove this degree restriction so the
lemma says that X is that the sum of G
of a is zero so for H if and only if X
divides G of X is a polynomial and so
what does this mean kind of if you
expand X divides G of X you get that
there exist some G prime such that G of
X is equal is identical to G prime of X
times X and the degree of G prime is
kind of less than agree of G by it by
one you can also get something similar
for additive subgroups of F but the
multiplicative subgroup cases a kind of
easier to explain and I can actually do
the proof on this slide so let's say
that H the size of H is N and Omega is
an n3 of unity and F this means that
generates H then this the sum so I'm
gonna look at just a single monomial and
then we can kind of use linearity to get
the some food for G so the sum of X to
the I over over an H I can rewrite this
using the fact that only get generates H
to this sump so I just put Omega to the
J in place of a and then I just swap the
exponents and what I have is a sum of
roots of unity
so this each of these only go to the I
is some root of unity and in particular
if I is equal to zero then this is just
one is trivial root of unity and so it's
sum is and and otherwise it's a sum of
non trivial aru's immunity and they all
cancel out so if i is equal to 0 mod n
then this sum is and in other ways it's
just there
so now let's see what happens when we
apply this to G so by linearity what you
get is the sum over the coefficients
times the sum of the over the of each
monomial individually and all of them
vanish apart from the the constant term
because everything apart from the
constant is not equal to 0 mod mod N and
so you get n times C 0 and so this means
that the sum of a H of G of a is equal
to 0 if and only if this the C 0 is 0
because n is not 0 in that field ok and
this means that X divides G of X very
because there's no constant term that
everything is divisible by X ok
good stuff so how do we move now to the
general case so in the general case the
statement is a little bit more
complicated looking so now we have so
now we have F being kind of a general
polynomial over the field and what we
get is that the sum of F is 0 if and
only if this expression holds so there
exist some polynomial H such that F
minus H times the 0 polynomial h divided
by the monomial X has degree less than
the size of H minus 1 and H is of kind
of small degree ok and how do we how do
we prove this you basically use
polynomial division to reduce to the
previous case so I divide F by Z H this
gives me F and F is identical to H times
H plus G with the degree of G less than
the size of H and then if I look at this
sum well I kind of expanded the causing
to this this identity I get H of a times
at H of a plus G of a and this thing
here is just 0 because the zet H
polynomial is 0 on H and so this is just
the sum of of G and we can use the fact
that the degree of G is less than the
size of H to use the ulema from the
previous slide to show that G is
divisible by by X and what this means is
that G prime which is this kind of F
minus H times G H divided by X right so
we kind of we take this G and we kind of
go back and we see what it is
has degree less than the size of H minus
one any questions about this
okay then okay then then we're gonna use
this to design a protocol so it's kind
of straightforward what you do so you
just take this this expression you say
okay the what I have to do is I have to
test the degree of this thing so the we
have both have access to F and the
prover is going to compute this this
decomposition and then he's gonna send
me the evaluation of H and this is this
kind of there exists H and then we do a
little bit test and we do a load of you
test to make sure that kind of F minus H
times H over H of X is a degree of less
of degree less than H minus 1 and the
degree of H is a most agreeable notice
that I don't need to send this thing
because the verifier is able to compute
it himself just by evaluating kind of F
and H and CH and and X all of these
things he had likes of do ok any
questions about univariate subject
okay that's good to you or I've just
completely lost everybody never mind
let's just
either way the correct reaction is to
move on so now we're going to talk about
the the complexity of the verifier so
kind of a little yep sorry
right so I understand this protocol
where you ldt this function yep
assuming it was something great the
thing I'm used to is you give H and G or
you give G implicitly yep and a rant no
you give G Prime actually and then you
check on a random is f equal to H times
Z plus G is yes wondering if those two
things are equivalent like that H and so
they I mean okay they are not equivalent
and actually doing it this way gives you
kind of a better sound a Sarah I think
they're probably the same up to some
constant like you know they give you
they both give you a protocol that works
but the soundless error in this case is
better because in the other case you
have this kind of odd trade-off between
the the P I T pot and the low degree
test pot yeah so but formally like when
when we originally came over this
protocol it was designed like this and
then there was this this kind of
noticing that you don't actually need to
do this this P I T actually saved to
even with quite a lot in terms of like
concrete sounds okay so now that I've
talked about kind of the base of the
protocol I wouldn't talk about the
complexity of the verify which is kind
of a very important thing when you're
actually designing these snugs because
the verifies complexity and the snark is
essentially inherited from the verifies
complexity in there in the IOT okay so
what is the verifier doing in the IOP
well okay we're gonna break him down
into three bits there's this reduction
part which basically takes the instance
and reduces it to an instance of some
check there is the actual subject pot
and then there is the low degree test so
here we use the free low degree test of
BBA charity
the subject pot is very efficient
because computing these essentially the
only thing you have to do is kind of one
division in the field and then
evaluating this this vanishing
polynomial and because H is structured
it's actually very easy to to compute
this vanishing polynomial so this takes
roughly log n time low degree test is
also very efficient once again the time
this log in and so basically all of the
cost of the verifier is going to be in
this reduction part so let's look at
this a little bit more closely so here
we have this vector U of linearly
independent polynomials and what is the
kind of reduction what's the job of the
reduction well if you kind of trace
through what you need from the reduction
of like once you do the Sun check and
the low degree test basically it's
evaluating this polynomial at some
arbitrary alpha beta in the field so
remember that this U is like the low
degree extension of this U and this um
is lower ascension of n transpose times
u okay so what is the cost of this
computation so if you make a sensible
traceview and actually this is why we
don't use this power in construction
because we don't know how to do this
have you make a sensible trace of U then
you can actually compute this by verad
it's the evaluate this bivariate
extension in log h filled operations and
so really the main computational task is
computing this u sub m and this is a
kind of a good sign right because really
this use of m is the only thing and the
whole computation that depends on the
instance everything else is generic like
would apply to every instance and so
really computing u sub m should be the
main the main computational difficulty
if we're doing our job right what the
choice of this thing I can even write it
down so the answer is that this so this
this bivariate polynomial is going to be
the following
so this is kind of the magic polynomial
that makes everything work and basically
it looks kind of like like if I take my
if I if I take a matrix which is H by H
and I put some stuff on the diagonal we
don't have control over what's on the
diagonal but there's some stuff that's
not zero and then you put zeros
everywhere else this you XY is like the
load rear extension of this time and so
if I like take the U vector that is kind
of the that this is the load of
recession of then this gives me the the
properties that I want
okay all right so let's talk about how
you compute this this u sub m and
actually it turns out that the different
ways of computing you serve and
basically give you the three protocols
that I talked about before so let's kind
of do this taxonomy so let's just say
that I naively compute u sub m just by
doing Lagrange interpolation I just work
out kind of what it's supposed to be on
the kind of the systematic part and I
just interpolate this gives you
basically the original Aurora protocol
so you can do this in time order of N
and it works for all matrices on the
other hand if you notice that your M is
structured so that u sub M can be
computed by this algebraic tensor
product that I'll talk about in a little
bit then this gives you a 16 verifier
for these structured so succinct
matrices now if you're if you're willing
to do some kind of like holographic
encoding of the input then you can
combine this with a protocol for doing
matrix arithmetician 2 which is based on
some work with called marlin
and this will allow you to compute this
bivariate lde in time order of log n so
like once you've eartha ties this matrix
so this there is some matrix that's
related to M that this is the
arithmetician of and so you get a
logarithmic verifier and you're a lot
you can support all matrices but you pay
the cost of kind of encoding the input
at the beginning
yes the verifier like some someone who
is like it doesn't have to be the
verifying it just has to be someone that
you trust because they you know
and particularly you can do it once for
a circuit and then everybody can use
this as long as they trust you so and I
mean trust also in not in the sense of
trusted set up like there's nothing that
that kind of is you know you just needs
to trust me to do the computation right
you could check it yourself okay so in
the last part that part of the talk I'm
going to talk about the kind of other
two constructions so firstly I'm going
to talk about the sixteenth construction
so like what is six inked islands yes
alright what are these sixteen matrices
I've been talking about so let's say
that you have a repeated circuit right
so your circuit basically just you know
you have the small component C and your
circuit is just like si si si si si over
and over again then when you turn it
into it into an all NCS instance using
kind of the standard reduction if you're
reasonably careful what you get is a
matrix that looks like this it's kind of
this like it's mostly zeros apart from
this thing down the middle we call it a
staircase matrix as it looks a little
bit like a staircase so this this type
of matrix it turns out is like very nice
algebraically and why is that well if I
divide em which is this this
representation of kind of C and the y is
if I divide M into M 0 and M 1 then what
I get is this these kind of this like
double block diagonal matrix so it has M
0 on the diagonal like blocks of M 0 on
the diagonal and then blocks of M 1 on
the super diagonal and so if I write
this using intensive product notation I
get that this is the kind of identity on
on n where n is the number of copies of
C times M 0 plus the this kind of
shifted identity so this is the matrix
with just ones on the super diagonal
tensor product with with M one so
roughly this captures wiring like M 0
captures wiring and inside of a block
and M 1 captures wiring kind of between
the blocks right you need this overlap
and will to make these computations
append with each other
you can also bootstrap this this is
actually very very general form of
matrix you can kind of bootstrap this
protocol to check Ram complete
yes is whether there should be sort of
the tulip this for the C's take
independent inputs so sort of updated
parallel Thanks
that's a good question I haven't thought
about that
so for now we're actually gonna throw
out this other this top pot and just
think about matrices which I have these
on the block diagonal these don't really
represent interesting computations but
we'll this is kind of easier to talk
about and the ideas that we use here can
be used to check this more general form
you should note that the if you've if
this looks familiar this is kind of
because it looks a bit like a quantum
gate right like if I have a single qubit
gate then the way that I kind of write
it down as a matrix is I just tensor it
with the identity on all of the other
qubits I don't know that this has any
you know particular ramifications
basically because this is a ver finite
field but I know it's an interesting
thing to note
I guess so the interesting thing is that
we didn't invent this kind of 16
representation of computation right it
come sort of has a history okay so what
we're going to need to do is we're going
to need to define our tensor product in
a way that is kind of algebraically
friendly so the we're going to need to
like have this tensor product then it
needs to play well with all of our like
glow degree extensions and things like
that so let's just look briefly at how
you do that so I'm gonna take my H which
is subset of the field and I'm going to
kind of decompose it into this product
h2 times each one and then I have a map
PI 1 and PI 2 Maps PI 1 and PI 2 and
they take it to like the the coordinates
in this in this matrix right so it takes
it so like H 1 H 2 where H 1 is PI 1 of
H and H 2 is PI 2 of H and this is a
bijection okay so now if I have these
two vectors X and after the H 1 and y
enough to the H 2 then I can take that
out of product and I get this matrix
which is the XY transpose and then if I
like use this the inverse of this map to
lay this out as a vector what I get is
this extensive way so this is kind of
the map so you know so far so basic
linear algebra so what is kind of
interesting about this
about this kind of object it turns out
that in if we are careful about our
choice of H then we can actually make
these maps PI 1 and PI 2 be low degree
functions so we can think of these maps
as being polynomials such that kind of
their restriction 2h has this property
that it like gives you this product and
moreover the degree is pretty low so the
degree of Pi 1 is the size of H 2 and
the degree of Pi 2 is size of H 1 and
even better they can be evaluated very
fast so these polynomials can be
evaluated anywhere in the field in
logarithmic time ok this actually this
uses heavily the group structure of H we
don't know how to do this if H doesn't
have recharge so what does this give us
this gives us kind of an algebraic like
low degree extension of the tensor
product right so I can write down this
function X tense a hat Y and if I have a
low tier extension of X and a load
retention of Y represented by X hat my
hat then I can plug in these PI 1 and PI
2 things and I can get something which
is essentially a low degree extension of
x and y of sorry of X 10 so what it is
not the unique low degree extension of
extends away but it's kind of good
enough so it has degree which is kind of
twice as big as it needs to be which is
pretty good and it agrees with extensive
Y on this set H so what is this bias
well we can basically the the message is
that you can efficiently compute and
some LD of X 10 so Y given L DS of x and
y using this construction okay so how do
we use this to test these succinctly
near relations well what you do you look
at this kind of this matrix and now I've
kind of made it more algebraic looking
so this is a the identity on H on H 1
and M 0 which is an H 2 by H 2 matrix
and then kind of this this M here is
that the tensor product of these two
things where I buy tensor product I mean
this like H 1 H 2 tensor product
now if this this map here is a
homomorphism this is where we use in the
group structure then there exists these
to use uh-1 and uh-2 such that this
vector of linear linearly independent
polynomials you that I want I can
realize it as the tensor product of uh-1
and uh-2 and moreover I can find these
bivariate extensions that I that I'm
looking for in time luggage so what's
nice about this well this is compatible
with kind of the tensor in M and so what
I do is I look at M transpose u I when I
do this multiplication by kind of the
because the multiplication distributes
over the tensor product I get u h1 in
the first coordinate right so this just
this is the identity applied to the
first coordinate and then this M 0
transpose is applied to this second like
part of the tensor and this part like m0
I'm thinking of as being small so I can
just kind of directly compute the LD
this is my like non uniform like core
and recall that if we can compute X hat
Y hat efficiently then we can produce we
can compute a load recession of the
tensor product and this means that kind
of by this equation we can compute the
this you and um in time log n so
basically you wanted to get individual
degree down to square root n and then
your you can do even a bivariate
extension because it's time go event so
going square that's the no this is a
this is not really about degrees this is
just about like you mean oh you mean
this thing
oh so this is not screwed and so you
can't afford to do it by various no this
sorry this actually it has absolutely
nothing to do with that tool so this is
just really about about like we're not
really doing anything with degrees or
anything like that we're just saying ok
like I have I have some like you which
is a vector linear linear demand
polynomials and I want to compute the
loner
extension of n transpose U and so I'm
using the structure of M to say that
they can do this fast but like really
the like in fact maybe the best way to
think about it is is that from the
provers perspective nothing has changed
really like the prover is doing the same
work in this protocol as he's doing in
the Aurora protocol except that he makes
a different choice of you
yeah and I'm saying why is M 0 T times u
H easier oh this because it's small
sorry so m0 is really tiny like you
think of m0 as being like like you know
log size so I'm thinking of this this
matrix is being made up of like lots and
lots of tiny blocks so this may be this
is a misleading picture because they're
only got 5 of these but you should think
of it of having like a million of them
yes yeah exactly
yeah yeah so this is a okay I see where
the confusion comes from yes so this
isn't to do with degrees or anything
like that this is just to do with kind
of you want to make your your verify
kind of linear only in the part that's
like not uniform sorry that yep there's
not uniform okay
alright so now I'm briefly going to talk
about this new protocol so this is a two
protocols fractal and Marlin fractal is
in IOP and Marlin is for something that
supports kind of polynomial commitments
so this is this is a kind of non post
quantum version and this is from two
very recent papers from kind of last
week so in the holographic setting what
you can do is you can take your matrix m
and you can encode it using some some
error correcting code and then you can
write it down and have the verify kind
of query so one natural thing to do is
to write down the evaluation of U sub m
right and so you know this is this is
kind of the polynomial that I want and
as an encoding of M so I could do it the
problem is that the encoding is really
big which means that the time to encode
is a lot and we care about the time to
encode because it's kind of a cost that
we have to pay in the proof system if
you didn't care about the time to encode
actually this will be pretty good so the
idea is that you encode m using these
kind of in a sparse representation using
polynomials row call and Val we're kind
of if I look at row of one and call of
one a valid one I get like the first the
like where the first entry in the matrix
is the first nonzero entry in the matrix
is and what its value is so this is like
a sparse representation of M and this is
of size kind of the number of nonzero
entries of M the problem then is kind of
how do I go from this bus encoding to
this use of M and the answer is
essentially this this equation so this
equation basically gives you the low
degree ascension of a matrix in terms of
these row column Val polynomials and you
can show that kind of in order to
compute sub M you need to basically
compute the load recession of an like
modulo some real waiting so what is this
well this EQ sub H is the polynomial the
like the bivariate polynomial where if I
give it kind of a and B and H then it's
zero if a is not B and one if a is equal
to B and so this says kind of I'm
summing over K and K and I want to check
kind of
is this the correct row is this the
correct column if so then give me now
that's the basic idea this is kind of
hiding some details because this is
actually a very high degree problem
really needs to deal with that but this
is kind of the basically how this
protocol works and that's kind of all I
have time to say about that all right so
thank you very much
this is all of this stuff was based on
these three papers two of which are
online now and one of which is going to
be online very soon I promise
and if you're interested in kind of how
this all looks as a as like a landscape
this diagram will explain you can
explain to you kind of how to check any
all in CS instance you would like thank
you tears of things which are small or
that we know how to evaluate yeah you
know then we can evaluate the low degree
extension right yeah so you know you
have the
you can compute the low degree
extensions of a tensor product
efficiently is there some other you know
are there some other interesting
operations that you can also you know
that also commutes with taking a little
bit degrees interesting so I mean this
that it doesn't actually commute the
taking a little retention right do kind
of you lose something and with doing
this you could take multiple tensor
products this is one one kind of simple
generalization I yeah I'm I don't know
of anything anything else I guess the
the one thing that we have thought about
is kind of like we only have really -
like matrices that we can put on the
left here right now right we have this
kind of identity and then the like
shifted version of the identity these
are not very exciting matrices maybe
there are more interesting matrices that
you can kind of put on the left and they
need to be really like very structured
because there's a uniform part
when asked about the basic version of a
linear of application time yes
reputation parameter for the movie
because yes yeah so the the you can
think of the linear as being multiplied
by this repetition parameter is should
be bigger than say lagers right so I
mean it's like it's like the security
parameter right it's like older of the
security parameter V gives you context
you Logan
but these sake foster right right so yes
you can
so if you if you're making lots of
queries then you could conceivably just
you could use the FFT to rather than
doing Lagrange interpolation over and
over again I think there is you know and
if you actually try and do it that's
kind of a trade-off in terms of like the
number of queries whether that makes
sense
I know I'm saying like in the real world
yes so in the in the like theoretically
I think that you're right that kind of
the the right asymptotic is like an log
and or something if you want to get like
negligible soundness but yeah I think so
we actually don't do this in practice
[Laughter]
any more questions oh yeah say now we go
to the trusted set of non quantum like
broad sixteen I know my circuit is many
just even on independent and just
independent copies of the same smaller
circuit yeah there any chance that this
tensor stuff can improve something there
like the proving time I okay I don't
know about proving so like this doesn't
help us with proving very much I think
there's something that you can do but
it's not you know I somatically it
doesn't help I think that there is some
it has some scope to be applied to cross
16 type things also may be bulletproof
type things I was like it seems like
this is kind of a general notion of
succinctness that that should be
applicable in any well you that you want
to use ah yes but I haven't looked into
it
[Applause]